hey legal eagles law school starts in
August so you know what that means time
to get a new backpack every law student
needs a backpack it's unavoidable but
there are lots of options out there and
law school has a really particular
requirements for what makes for a good
or bad backpack so today we're gonna
discuss what I think the best options
are for a backpack or bag in law school
by the end of this video you'll know
exactly what law school backpack to buy
so stick around law school is probably
the last time in your life that a
backpack is a mandatory requirement it's
also probably the last time that wearing
a backpack at all times is socially
acceptable I don't really know why
they're really functional so here are a
few reasons why you should get a good
sturdy backpack or messenger bag in law
school number one you are most likely
going to be carrying your case books to
and from class even if you don't use
them in class which most people don't
you might want to read them in the
library before after class for homework
purposes this is a case book they are
big and heavy and they're really bulky
so you need a heavy-duty backpack that
is capable of carrying multiple case
books without crushing your back now
number two you're going to be taking
your laptop with you 24/7 laptops are
for law students what water is to a fish
you would die without it
so you're going to use your laptop to
take notes in class to write your
outlines and most importantly when you
go on social media when you need a break
from law school now you won't go
anywhere without your laptop so your
backpack needs to have a dedicated space
to hold and protect your laptop now
number three you're probably going to
have all manner of electronic doodads
like chargers and mice and cords and
writing implements like pens and pencils
and highlighters and additionally you're
probably going to have a few snacks and
caffeinated liquids in your backpack so
you need to have a way to organize all
of that stuff together so without
further ado here are my main
requirements for a law school backpack
number one it must be big it has to be
big enough to carry at least two case
books number two it has to be able to
carry your laptop and protect it so you
don't destroy it number three your
backpack must be durable so it holds up
for at least one year and preferably all
three years in law school so generally
there are three types of backpacks or
bags that law students use in law school
number one there is the regular old
backpack it's got two straps it's got a
flap at the top it might have some
zippers but this is the backpack that
you think of when you think of a
backpack number two is the messenger bag
or something that looks like a really
big purse these are the ones that
generally have one shoulder strap you
sling it over and it's generally one big
pocket with a flap over it and number
three is the Rolly bag we just sort of a
hybrid between a backpack and the
rolling suitcases that you see at an
airport those are the three main types
of backpacks that you see on a law
school campus let's talk about the first
category of options this is the
traditional backpack on law school
campuses you'll see a couple of brands
more often than not the first brand is
Swiss skier here are a couple examples
of a Swiss skier backpack they've got
the red square with the white or silver
plus sign in the middle of it not unlike
what you see on a Swiss Army knife
I had a Swiss skier backpack throughout
my entire career in college and
undergrad I loved it that thing was a
tank and it held up beautifully these
things are generally cheap they're
pretty durable they're not the most
fashion-forward option but I can
personally vouch that my personal Swiss
gear backpack lasted four years possibly
even through high school now that I
think about it but for me when I got to
law school a chest strap that went
across my chest was a must I find that
it does a really good job of helping
shoulder the burden take some of the the
weight off of my shoulders and put it on
to my chest
you'll see these a lot on hiking
backpacks so I upgraded to an OG o
backpack this is my OG o back
this is an OG Oh gambit it's big enough
to hold a 17 inch laptop it's got a
separate pocket for a laptop it's got
pockets all over the place it easily
holds multiple electronic devices and it
seems to be as well-built as the Swiss
skier option that I had throughout
undergrad and most importantly it has a
chest strap so that it can help shoulder
the weight of all the case books that I
had the og o is a little bit more
expensive but I found it to be
invaluable in law school and even after
I still have it another option is the
Herschel backpack these are very popular
right now they are the more fashionable
of the traditional backpack options this
is a Herschel backpack that I borrowed
from a friend you can see it's got a
traditional top flap it's got the
leather straps in the front and but
mainly consists of one large pocket with
a laptop holder and then a smaller
pocket on the front so you are paying
for some of that fashionable nough swiff
less of the organizational features but
my friend bought one it held up great
until one of the front straps broke but
Herschel had a great replacement policy
and they sent a new bag within a week so
I can say that the warranty is good in
this the second one has held up
beautifully by the way you can find
links to all of the backpacks and bags
that I'm discussing today down in the
description below that will take you
directly to the Amazon link for the
product so finally in the traditional
backpack category you have brands like
REI and Burton I've never owned one of
those myself but they are very popular
on law school campuses right now and
based on the reviews that I've read they
also sound like they make really good
options for law school backpacks as well
so I'll leave some links to those
particular backpacks in the in the
description below ok so that takes me to
the second category of backpack or bag
that you see in law school and that is
the messenger bag some people just
cannot bring themselves to use a
traditional backpack frankly I get it
back
pax forum is really not as good as its
function and they are not the most
fashionable things to wear around so for
my friends that went the non backpack
route most of them went with a messenger
bag and particularly a messenger bag
from a company called Tim buck - here's
a couple examples of those messenger
bags I can tell you from personal
experience that my friends who use these
messenger bags were able to use them for
multiple years they held up beautifully
and they fit a surprising amount of
weight the only downside is that
generally you're using these as a one
strap messenger bag and so all of the
weight of your case books is going to be
shouldered on one shoulder so from what
I saw my friends who had these messenger
bags were very happy with them they
seemed to be spacious enough for case
books and laptops and most of them had
dedicated pockets for laptops and they
appeared to be very durable and most
importantly these messenger bags were
very very high quality polyester
unfortunately I can't recommend any
messenger bag that's made of leather or
any purse that's made of leather there's
no doubt that leather messenger bags and
attache cases and purses look amazing
but I have never seen a leather bag that
was durable enough to survive law school
so I can recommend the the bags from
Timbuktu but I can't recommend
unfortunately any leather messenger bags
so that brings me to the third category
of bags and backpacks and that is the
infamous Rolly bag so if the messenger
bag is the really fashionable option the
traditional backpack is the sort of
middle option well then Rolly bags are
gonna be on the other end of the
spectrum and those are for people who
just don't care what they look like and
want the absolute most comfortable
option that's what Rolly bags do these
are bags that are sort of hybrid between
rolling luggage that you see in airports
where you just kind of roll it along on
its wheels but as sort of an
afterthought they have some straps like
a traditional backpack Rolly bags are
pervasive in
school so don't be afraid of looking
like a dork if you decide to choose a
rolling bag there's nothing wrong with
it no one's gonna look down on you
people understand that case books are
really heavy laptops are heavy all of
the junk that you're gonna have and your
backpack is really heavy so it's
perfectly acceptable to use a Rolly bag
when you get to law school there will be
lots of people who likewise value
function over form and buy a Rolly bag
for their stuff there's sort of two
options when you're talking about Rolly
bags first is what I would say that most
lawyers use when they actually go to
court these are generally referred to as
document bags they have one large
central area where you can hold reams
and reams of paper or in the case of a
law student their case books and their
laptop it's got lots of space but
there's sort of no frills and they are
meant to get lots of paper from one area
to the other if you are dead set on
saving money and want to buy the thing
that you're going to use most likely in
practice the document bag like this one
is probably your best bet
that is what lawyers bring into court
when they graduate from law school
alternatively you can get a hybrid
backpack with wheels for example this
one from high sierra has wheels on the
bottom but also straps like a
traditional backpack this is probably
what you'll see more of in law school
something that is sort of like a real
backpack but has some wheels built into
it so that you can carry it like a
backpack when you're walking over dirt
or grass but you can use the wheels when
you are walking over concrete so those
are the main options when you're talking
about backpacks bags and Rolly bags
there is no one right answer you have to
choose for yourself you'll see that law
students are split roughly 1/3 for each
category so whatever route you choose
there will be other students like you
who made similar decisions and frankly
you really can't go wrong so get the
backpacker bag that works for you so
that's one less thing you have to worry
about for when you start law school in
the fall for even more strategy
and tactics on how to hit the ground
running when you get to law school
please download our free ultimate
pre-law checklist the link is below it
will give you a head start when you get
to law school and also please click on
the like and subscribe buttons the more
people subscribe the more videos will
make on how to crush law school so did I
miss a great backpack what's your
favorite backpack let me know in the
comments below and until next time at
legal eagle think like a lawyer and ace
the exam law school starts in August so
you know what that means a new backpack
again another option is a Herschel
backpack these are a little